[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP pendant une
heure autour d'un plat et d'un dessert
avec notre invité nous allons parler
alimentation agriculture écologique et
aussi politique et cette semaine nous
recevons Raphaël chez l'Ender bonjour
bonjour et bienvenue à vous et avec moi
pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigitte bonjour Raphaël berger
vous êtes député les républicains du
Haut-Rhin né à Mulhouse vous avez étudié
les sciences politiques à l'Université
de Strasbourg vous avez été maire de
Wattwiller plus jeune mère d'Alsace vous
êtes à droite l'un des spécialistes des
questions d'énergie pour avoir
Fessenheim dans votre circonscription ce
qui vous a amené à présider la
commission d'enquête parlementaire
visant à établir les raisons de la perte
de souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique de la France vous êtes aussi
depuis 2019 secrétaire général adjoint
des républicains chargez de la formation
de l'école des cadres et de l'Alsace
alors Haut-Rhin Mulhouse Strasbourg
Wattwiller Fessenheim Alsace à mon avis
sont parallèles pour ces déjeuners
Jean-Pierre bienvenue Brigitte parce
qu'au menu l'Alsace est célébré avec un
fleischnaka et on desserre une tarte aux
myrtilles dans le dessous des plats à la
découverte des fermes auberge une
tradition vosgienne en vogue depuis le
19e siècle qui a les traditions et
produits locaux reportage dans cette
émission dans les pays dans plein la
route des vins d'Alsace faite ses 70 ans
l'occasion d'une belle balade au milieu
des vignes et des châteaux
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
alors Raphaël chêne berger je n'ai rien
contre les alsaciens qui soient députés
comme vous de la société civile comme
Dominique Schoelcher un patron de Super
U natif de colmarck on a reçu à votre
place il a quelques semaines mais bon
s'il vous plaît en tant que membre du
même club géographique j'allais dire
concertez-vous les gars deux alsaciens
ici à table et deux menus identiques
avec cette imprononçable au moins pour
un parigot ce fameux flèche Naka alors
ku double comme si la cuisine alsacienne
se résumait à cet escargot de viande
comme vous dites là-bas alors la
première fois avec Brigitte je veux bien
on s'est dit c'est le charme de la
découverte un voyage culinaire en terre
inconnu bref une pointe d'exotisme mais
là je vous l'avoue avec franchise pas
vraiment un goût comme on le dit de
reviens-y et pourtant donc grâce ou à
cause de vous rebelote un flèche
nakamiste que vous avez vous-même
apporté alors on aurait préféré le BK
off par exemple ou même une vieille
choucroute des familles donc à vous de
jouer cher ami et nous persuader
fourchettes en main que ce plat et
l'alpha et l'oméga de la cuisine
alsacienne je sais pas s'il est l'alpha
et le méga de la cuisine alsacienne je
vous avoue que je n'avais pas vu que
Dominique schœlcher qui vient de
d'ailleurs de Fessenheim donc dans ma
circonscription avant moi vers amené le
même sens je l'ai découvert hier donc je
ne l'avais pas quand on a préparé le
menu mais en fait c'est un plat
emblématique de ce qu'elle Alsace et
c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi ce plat
parce que c'est un simple plat du
lendemain c'est un plat où on revient
après avoir cuisiné le pot-au-feu avec
les restes avec les restes d'autres
choses pour vraiment cuisiner c'est à
dire accommoder ce qu'il y a et un plat
de reste en fait c'est les restes du
pot-au-feu qu'on met dans dans les
flychnaka moi je sais il y a encore
quelques quelques familles ou des
endroits où ce genre d'institutions se
reproduisent on parlera tout à l'heure
de vin à l'époque des vendanges les
familles de viticulteurs
pour manger les vignerons enfin les
vendangeurs le midi le premier jour il y
a du pot-au-feu le lendemain il y a des
flychnaka parce que c'est la viande
cuite qu'on va mettre dedans c'est
vraiment je vous raconte un peu comment
on peut le faire pour ceux qui sont pas
alsacien parce que c'est intéressant
aussi que les non alsaciens commencent à
faire ce genre de recette ça peut être
intéressant et c'est vraiment de la
cuisine parce que c'est la cuisine c'est
faire avec ce qu'on a c'est pas
seulement suivre des recettes qu'on
connaît et c'est ça je crois ça
représente bien l'Alsace aussi de
savoir-faire
du pauvre parce que c'est c'est quand
même un plat qui est riche il y a de la
viande il y a de la pâte c'est
travailler mais c'est une façon de
travailler ce qui reste et je trouve que
c'est une belle histoire alors dans le
juste je voulais dire Brigitte que dans
le match schelen berger Shelter je
dirais chez Hélène berger vainqueur
parce que celle-ci est plus jolie que la
dernière fois on a pas goûté est-ce que
je peux vous assurer c'est que j'ai vu
que Dominique Schoelcher ils avaient
commandé chez traiteur Paris alsacien à
Paris Schmidt et je voulais RAM ène de
la boucherie Laurent dans la vallée de
la tour voilà ramener cette semaine
parce que bon nous aussi on est on est
curieux de découvrir ce flechta
vous aviez bien aimé Brigitte la
dernière fois
j'avais découvert alors il y a moins de
bouillon que la dernière fois et en
principe ça se sert dans plus de
bouillon ou pas alors
j'ai envie de dire qu'il y a deux
religions
si vous êtes si vous allez dans un
restaurant en Alsace et que vous
commandez des flyer la plupart des
vinstub la plupart des restaurants
traditionnels vont vous proposer des
flèches à la carte vont le servir dans
du bouillon d'accord dans ma famille on
les cuisine dans de la sauce tomate donc
c'est voilà mais c'est des traditions de
famille un petit peu
à l'italienne
plus aérienne il y a moins de pattes
vous avez une idée des épices c'est de
la cuisine chacun il va un petit peu à
sa façon certains peuvent mettre un peu
de fromage épicé quelques légumes des
carottes pour pour relever la farce et
c'est en fait il y a plein de recettes
de flechters
aussi qu'on déforme un peu différente le
principe c'est que on est à la pâte
prend la roue là je raconterai ça ouvre
là on la roule certains font les fonds
immédiatement individuellement c'est des
formes plus plus ovales mais c'est
toujours le même principe c'est de
d'accommoder les restes de viande dans
un plat cuisiné mais vous nous avez vous
m'avez fait mentir parce que je disais
pas de goût de reviens si on y revenant
on les découvre et bravo on est conquis
bon donc si je peux vous convaincre de
venir en Alsace autant que vous le
voudrez
trois astuces du coup à savoir pour
réussir quand on n'est pas alsacien
alors effectivement c'est si un jour on
a des restes de pot-au-feu bien c'est
l'occasion de se lancer dans le flèche
Naka vous conservez les restes de viande
vous les hachez menu et vous les faites
revenir avec un oignon mais après vous
avez raison on peut rajouter plein de
petites choses du persil de l'ail pour
pas je crois que là il sait pas
forcément une bonne chose mais oignon et
en tous les cas persil préparez une pâte
dite alors la pâte à Spetz dans ces
fameuses
on va avoir du mal aujourd'hui
c'est pas très compliqué à faire ensuite
on l'étale on dispose donc cette fameuse
farce qu'on a fait avec les restes de
pot-au-feu haché et puis ensuite on la
roule comme un boudin et alors j'ai une
petite astuce pour ceux qui vont se
lancer dans cette aventure mais vous la
mettez 20 minutes au congélateur comme
ça ce boudin va un peu durcir et ça sera
plus facile ensuite de les couper en
petites tranches comme ça on peut les
faire d'ailleurs là elle est assez
épaisse mais on peut faire deux
centimètres et ensuite on les fait
revenir un peu dans la poêle et on les
met comme la dit Raphaël chez le berger
dans un petit bouillon qu'on peut
agrémenter aussi de petits champignons
ou de sauce tomate
alors vous avez une recette que vous a
été transmise par votre grand-mère
l'arrière-grand-mère ou je ne sais je
suis incapable de vous le dire parce que
je n'en ai personnellement jamais
cuisinier j'en mange souvent et c'est
très pratique c'est vrai que les
débouchés chez nous en font et c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut assez
facilement acheter me souviens de
conserver au congélateur c'est des plats
finalement quand on a dans le
congélateur au frigo le soir ça arrive
souvent voilà 10 minutes dans du
bouillon et puis vous avez un plat très
facile très facile à manger qui était
déjà bon
j'en ai quand même pas à Paris faut pas
exagérer
mais c'est très facile finalement voilà
des plats de secours un petit peu
maintenant dans la famille vers la
recette de ma mère
elle est elle est cuisine à la sauce
tomate et alors vous il y en avait
souvent chez vous c'est un repas que qui
est très fréquent
régulièrement ma mère faisait
régulièrement ça je mangeais
régulièrement chez mes grands-parents
c'est un plat simple en fait et c'est
pour ça que j'aime le partager c'est pas
forcément le plat le plus connu en
Alsace
à l'opulence de la choucroute ou à la
complexité que peut être le pekko
c'est un plat qui nécessite beaucoup de
temps de cuisson
subtil l'équilibre entre l'eau et le vin
vous en parlez très bien mais est-ce que
vous êtes bon pour nous
je sais pas est-ce que vous y êtes de
temps en temps en tout cas j'apprécie
parfois de quand j'ai le temps de
prendre le temps de cuisiner recevoir un
petit peu les amis aussi même autour de
choses simples parce que c'est vrai que
la table c'est quand même un moment où
on arrive à avoir des échanges une
sincérité une convivialité qui est quand
même très importantes chez vous c'était
important le repas du dimanche par
exemple on se disait des choses qu'on se
disait pas autrement dans la semaine
pas forcément tant le repas du dimanche
mais même le repas du soir c'est vrai
que que jeûne j'étais dans une famille
ou où on mangeait ensemble tous les
soirs tous réunis
avec avec
l'agenda les métiers des uns des autres
mais le soir on mange à table c'est pas
c'est pas chacun prend quelque chose
pour manger dans son coin à l'américaine
on mange ensemble à table et je trouve
que c'est quelque chose d'important un
rendez-vous pour échanger surtout c'est
ça pour partager pour partager la
journée les préoccupations peut-être
qu'une partie de ma sensibilisation à la
vie politique vient aussi des échanges
en famille à table parce que on parle de
tout et on est ensemble pendant une
demi-heure pour pour dîner même si c'est
simple mais on est ensemble à table
alors l'Alsacien que vous êtes on a bien
connu vous êtes un bon ambassadeur de
cette gastronomie de ce terroir alsacien
mais est-ce que vous aimez aussi vous
aventurez comme nous on l'a fait avec
votre flèche Naka sur d'autres pistes
d'autres terrains d'autres cuisines
d'autres terroirs français avec vos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale ou
étrangers même on n'est pas là
l'Allemagne c'est peut-être pas la
meilleure référence mais peut-être que
vous allez vous dire que c'est une terre
de gastronomie
vous dire que l'Allemagne est une terre
de gastronomie je suis j'en serais
incapable par contre vous dire que je
suis curieux de la diversité culinaire
française et et culturel qui se
retrouvent dans la cuisine ailleurs oui
moi j'adore aller dans des régions
goûter les spécialités les découvrir
manger des plats de la mer quand on est
au bord de la mer manger du canard quand
on est dans le Sud-Ouest ou ailleurs
dans le bassin méditerranéen
voilà découvrir on a une culture
occidentale qui tourne quand même
beaucoup autour de la cuisine et
beaucoup de de l'identité de nos
territoires se dit dans les plats
j'adore les découvrir alors souvent le
plat préféré des Français c'est la pizza
le couscous c'est votre cas ou pas vous
voyez moi j'adore le flash
attention autre cheval identitaire on a
une crudité exceptionnelle en Alsace qui
s'appelle
la salade vigneronne qu'une salade de
saucisses formidable en matière de
crudités
qu'on connaît moins ou pas il y en a
beaucoup on aurait pu
une pâtisserie une brioche il y a
évidemment la tarte flambée oui voilà la
fameuse start plombée oui
qui le font en propose oui voilà
exactement mais il y a énormément c'est
une terre de cuisine et c'est les
spécialités alsaciennes sont toutes des
plats ce sont tous des plats cuisinés
mijoter voilà parce que c'est une
cuisine plutôt une région continentale
un peu froide dans laquelle on prend le
temps de préparer les choses on parlera
peut-être d'agriculteurs de montagne
tout à l'heure donc c'est des collègues
vous échangez parfois par exemple vous
apportez à fleischnaka il vous apporte
un Coulommiers je sais pas enfin il y a
des échanges qui se font comme ça on
troque pas je crois pas par contre c'est
vrai que quand on en a à l'occasion on
aime avoir l'occasion d'aller peut-être
dans la région d'un autre on va en
profiter pour pour découvrir les
spécialités locales voilà moi si je vais
dans une région qui a une forte
spécificité culinaire je vais goûter ce
qu'on fait là-bas je vais pas
cuisine asiatique cuisine d'Amérique du
Sud ça vous ça vous tente vous aimez ça
ou j'aime beaucoup la cuisine
méditerranéenne libanaise c'est pas très
loin orientale c'est une cuisine c'est
pareil qui est travaillée qui qui sent
le territoire le terroir là-bas avec des
épices avec
beaucoup de temps qui est passé à la à
la préparation voilà donc le monde
entier regorge de spécialités que j'ai
l'impression que vous franchissez pas
souvent la porte d'un restaurant chinois
ou vietnamien l'impression que vous avez
une pourtant c'est la mode maintenant
non moi je peux aller asiatique avec
avec plaisir il y a aussi beaucoup de
choses un petit peu japonais comme tout
le monde
thaïlandais très très belles choses
aussi voilà moi j'aime les choses un peu
typiques et alors avec ce flechta vous
nous avez apporté un un vin blanc
d'Alsace qui est un Sylvaner c'est un
millésime 2021
c'est un cépage qu'on trouve aussi en
Autriche et en Allemagne et c'est une
appellation AOC donc appelle son origine
contrôlée et il a la particularité
d'être assez fruité d'être un peu
velouté un peu rond
pourquoi ce choix de vin qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça exprime pour vous pour
moi c'est le vin qui représente le mieux
le terroir alsacien peut-être que
certains viticulteurs vont avoir le poil
qui se hérissent en entendant ça mais ça
va là aussi simple
sec j'aime les vins blancs secs parfois
on a eu tendance à faire des vins un peu
sucrés en Alsace c'est pas forcément la
tradition j'aime les vins secs les
Sylvaners c'est toujours c'est toujours
sec c'est très simple c'est un vin qui
était vraiment un vin commun il y a
quelques décennies en Alsace qui est un
peu reculé dans le vignoble parce que
c'était une vigne très généreuse on en a
arraché on la remplacé par du pinot gris
mais voilà c'est un vin historique un
des cépages historique du vin d'Alsace
un des cépages qu'on trouve en France
qu'en Alsace
le vignoble alsacien est un vignoble
compliqué à vendre parce que il y a 7
cépages on fait pas trop d'assemblages
on vend plutôt des des
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler mais de
qualité
qui est pas cher je crois que quelque
chose que peut dire aussi globalement le
vignoble alsacien n'est pas un vignoble
cher pourtant fait de très belles choses
et Sylvaner est très bovins un peu
oublié et qui est vraiment pas cher et
c'est une des raisons aussi pour
lesquelles je souhaiterais partager ce
vin là
qui vont faire un flèche nacle après
mais les précieuses recommandations vous
vous préférez le blanc plutôt que le
rouge ou les deux vont aussi globalement
j'aime beaucoup le vin blanc donc c'est
pour ça c'est pour ça c'est l'assemblage
l'accord rouge flèche même si on fait du
très bon vin rouge aujourd'hui en Alsace
le vignoble l'Alsacien est réputé pour
120 blanc c'est pour ça que je vous ai
proposé du vin blanc après un pinot noir
alsacien ça passera très bien aussi avec
les Flyers
alors on va voir si vous êtes vraiment
un collable c'est le quiz
alors dernièrement Brigitte la rappelé
tout à l'heure vous avez mené dans
quatre parlementaires sur la filière
nucléaire vous êtes incollable sur
l'atome mais êtes-vous aussi sur la Tom
le fromage cette fois sauriez-vous nous
dire si ces affirmations suivantes sont
vraies ou fausses l'atome palatome pas
l'atome désigne un fromage à pâte molle
à croûte naturel vrai ou faux c'est faux
bravo c'est une pâte pressée non cuite
[Musique]
l'atome est un fromage forcément produit
dans les montagnes
ça je vous dirais vrai oui vrai ça vient
du patois Thomas qui veut dire fromage
des alpages 2 sur 2 la top chez nous
chez nous on l'appelle le barcase mais
nous on est pas chez nous en Algérie
la tomme de montagne en fait deux
fromages dans les montagnes le Munster
et le par casque qui est voilà pas de
pressé à partir du lait de vache de
montagne alors la tomme d'Alsace ça
s'écrit avec deux m ou un M parce que ça
nous a beaucoup agité parce que il y a
la taupe de l'arbre
[Rires]
c'est la tomme de sa voix avec deux m
bénéficie-t-elle d'une AOP vrai ou faux
alors dès qu'on sort de l'Alsace il est
perdu on a beaucoup d'aopé en France je
voudrais tendance à vous dire vrai faux
seulement une igpa et enfin
attention 13 exotique pour vous l'aligot
est préparé exclusivement avec de la
tomme fraîche de l'Aubrac et des pommes
de terre non mais je parlais du fromage
ecoutez je suis pas un spécialiste de
leur recette de la Ligue
je vous dirais vrai
que de l'Aubrac dans l'aligot alors
deuxième quiz alors là c'est pas facile
l'Alsace est connu pour son chenkélé
de carnaval
la provenance de ces autres douceurs qui
sont frites alors à la bugne est-ce que
la Lune vient de Provence d'Auvergne de
Lyon ou des Landes je dirais de Provence
alors de Lyon
est-ce que ça vient de Provence
d'Auvergne ou des Landes
on est sorti du terroir forcément
alors la couche pète c'est au sud de
Lyon
ou des Landes
alors non des Landes
plus que l'Auvergne après les citations
vous avez trouvé pas si mal finalement
ouais
et répétez-nous parce que moi je l'avais
écrit chenkélé oui mais bon alors là
vous rentrez dans une espèce de
polémique interne à l'Alsace sur la VA
prononciation est-ce que schengeler ou
shangala bon selon qu'on soit du Sud ou
du Nord
vous savez qu'en repas
politique le repas occupe une assez
large
plat et donc il y a toujours des petites
histoires des îles politiques qui se
font autour des repas c'est la brève de
comptoir
et alors on vous a demandé Raphaël
Sélène berger de réfléchir à une petite
anecdote autour d'un repas si possible
en politique est-ce que vous avez une
histoire à nous raconter ce qui était
très difficile d'y réfléchir c'est que
j'en aurai plein
non mais c'est vrai et parce que c'est
un moment important peut-être que si un
des repas qui m'ont un peu marqué c'est
c'était pendant le covid ou on pouvait
plus se retrouver à table on pouvait
plus bon aller au restaurant quand on
est à Paris c'est vrai que on mange
essentiellement au restaurant entre
parlementaire puisque on n'a pas
forcément l'endroit pour se faire la
cuisine et c'est vrai qu'on était sur le
bord de la ligne quoi on mangeait
ensemble dans mon bureau qui est un peu
plus grand que les autres il serait
qu'on se retrouvait toujours à quelques
collègues on se faisait livrer on se
faisait livrer à l'Assemblée nationale
et on se retrouvait ensemble pour quand
même partager
comme toujours en respectant un maximum
comme les règles mais finalement même
dans cette période là on a besoin
d'avoir un temps d'échange et le repas
c'est un temps d'échange donc on faisait
ça à 4 5 dans un grand bureau mais
c'était quand même un temps d'échange
c'est c'est ça c'est un message fort
c'est une forme de résilience aussi que
de dire même quand c'est dur on a besoin
d'un espace de partage le repas en est
un et ça me semblait important il y a
toujours des déjeuners clandestins dans
votre bureau ou ça vous y avez mis fin
on a peut-être même fait jusqu'à des
raclettes mais enfin ça c'est une autre
histoire dans le bureau
ça continue alors on va rester en Alsace
à présent dans le Haut-Rhin et découvrir
d'autres spécialités dans les fermes
auberge avec des plats cuisinés à partir
de produits de la ferme c'est le dessous
des plats
oui brigitte c'est une tradition plus
que séculaire dans le Haut-Rhin c'est
ferme auberge elles ont fait leur
apparition à la fin du 19e siècle avec
les premiers sentiers de promenade dans
la montagne en proposant aux randonneurs
de déguster les produits de la ferme
aujourd'hui elles sont devenues un vrai
atout pour le tourisme local
illustration avec la Ferme Auberge des
bâches dans la vallée de Monster
reportage de Pierre Michael Carniel
Marion Duvauchelle les Maïté Frémont je
vais encore faire taper les doigts
[Musique]
tu vas bien
mon mari et moi on a repris la ferme
auberge donc de mes beaux-parents en 92
maintenant il y a déjà notre fils avec
la belle-fille leur petit enfant et puis
donc c'est vraiment de génération en
génération c'est ça qui fait aussi le
charme la famille avant tout chez les
daibar la relève est assurée installé à
1000 mètres d'altitude en plein cœur des
Vosges depuis trois générations cette
famille propose un concept presque
oublié celui de la ferme auberge voilà
la base on a des éleveurs on aime nos
bêtes on aime notre massif on y prend
soin produire et fabriqué de bons
produits et ça c'est
c'est notre travail et puis c'est notre
fierté il est 6h du matin côté Ferme
Adrien le fils s'occupe de la traite de
ses vaches on produit environ 200 ml de
lait par an et 35 vaches laitière tous
les transformer sur site donc Antho en
Munster en crémeux notre nouveau fromage
et si ESCA sont fait notre glace et tout
ça ça part à l'auberge et un petit peu
dans des circuits courts pour obtenir le
label de ferme auberge le cahier des
charges est précis proposé au minimum
51% de produits issus de la ferme le
reste du repas devant être réalisé avec
des ingrédients du terroir locaux et de
saison
le fils ramène au père qui ramène à la
mer car au même moment côté auberge
Marie-Ève la mer est en cuisine voilà
merci bien elle commence à mitonner les
petits plats pour le midi donc on va
donc préparer nos roys
ce sont donc les pommes de terre au four
la spécialité qui va avec le repas
marqué chaque fois par couche avec des
oignons des pommes de terre et donc
naturellement en Alsace un bon petit vin
blanc
le repas marquèrent dédié à l'origine à
l'agriculteur du massif des Vosges je
vais préparer la tourte de La Valette de
Munster une farce à viande
ou je mets du porc
du veau
du persil des œufs du pain que je fais
tremper avec votre bon lait de vache
là donc la cuisson
[Musique]
une heure à 180 degrés environ 3 heures
plus tard tous prennent place dans le
restaurant dont la salle des randonneurs
mais pas que les femmes auberge c'est un
peu la destination touristique dans le
coin c'est ce qu'on fait tous les
dimanches
ce jour-là Marie avait sa famille auront
servi une trentaine de repas une
quarantaine de ferme auberge comme
celle-ci existent en Alsace ces lieux
des cautourismes créés au 19e siècle
sont aujourd'hui appréciées par les
Français friand de repas naturel
alors qu'un sort autrement pour le
terroir je me lance mais je pense que
vous les tartes auberge vous les avez
déjà fréquentés petit et même grand moi
c'est c'est les fermes auberge elles ont
une autre histoire que celle qui est
seulement le développement touristique
et les circuits courts c'est aussi des
lieux de de pâturage de estivaux c'est
des des alpages vos Giens donc les les
bêtes montaient l'été pour pour faire
mais c'est ça c'était essentiellement
des fermes et beaucoup de ces fermes
auberge était alors progressivement
c'est en train un peu de changer mais
propriété des communes parce que c'était
une ferme collective dans laquelle
chaque paysan du village nous est monté
c'est c'est bête pour pour l'été et la
commune dont j'ai été le maire va être
filaire et encore propriétaire de la
ferme auberge et de 30 hectares de près
qui sont autour alors aujourd'hui on le
met en location à exploiter par une un
fermier aubergiste
pour pour 9 ans enfin by classique et et
agricole classique et un bail commercial
sur sur la ferme mais c'est encore
beaucoup de ferme auberge qui sont comme
ça propriété des communes celle-ci c'est
visiblement la propriété de au fur et à
mesure ça ça a changé il y a maintenant
vendu par les communes
maintenant c'est essentiellement des
agriculteurs qui en sont propriétaires
le modèle économique a changé il y a
moins de paysans dans les villages qui
ont une bête qu'il montre l'été c'est un
modèle qui n'existe plus aujourd'hui et
donc ce sont des fermiers aubergistes il
y a quelques grandes familles vous avez
montré la famille dyber qui a une des
grandes familles de des fermes auberge
sur la sur la craie des Vosges
l'agriculture c'est quelque chose de
difficile mais c'est des métiers
passionnants et et ça se transmet et
quand on a vécu là-dedans souvent on a
envie de de reprendre et dans les fermes
auberge c'est particulièrement vrai ça
c'est l'histoire de ferme auberge on a
bien compris c'est très intéressant mais
vous vous êtes allés quand vous avez
commencé
[Musique]
alors j'ai jamais dormi en fait mon
berger
à la journée comme ça on verra on peut
aller juste déjeuner on peut randonner
sur les crêtes passer d'une ferme
auberge à l'autre et y passer la nuit
comme des petits en fait comme des comme
des refuges voilà propose propose
l'hébergement et je vous le dis j'ai été
maire d'une commune au pied d'un massif
avec sa ferme auberge je suis élu d'une
vallée
immensément riche en ferme auberge et
donc j'y vais très régulièrement
voilà on est début de semaine juste
avant de venir j'avais un déjeuner de
travail dans une ferme auberge vous
voyez c'est mais c'est pas trop loin de
votre chaîne d'être en plein cœur les
Vosges les Vosges c'est le massif le
plus aménagé de France c'est le massif
montagneux et c'est pas sans poser un
certain nombre de problèmes aujourd'hui
avec le tourisme avec la pression que
les nouvelles activités
nature de la population font exercer sur
sur la nature mais les Vosges c'est le
massif le plus densément peuplé de
France donc on est très
urbanisé disons c'est ça oui le plus
densement peuplé en tout cas il y a des
activités les faire auberge c'est une
vraie activité économique énormément le
tourisme justement c'est ferme auberge
ou c'est devenu à la mode ou salade
c'est évident alors ça fait une bonne
trentaine d'années que c'est vraiment
devenu un produit touristique je tiens
quand même à préciser qu'il y a pas eu
de construction de ferme auberge c'est
vraiment des fermes sont authentiques
qui sont authentiques alors parfois
construire une autre ferme-auberge
parce que on a transformé la grange en
salle de restaurant et on a construit
une nouvelle grange à côté pour adapter
la réalité de l'activité économique
aujourd'hui mais on n'a pas construit ex
nihilo des fermes auberge sur les dans
sur les crêtes puis ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il y a un cahier
des charges on peut pas aller manger
pourquoi il est pas question d'aller
manger de l'aligot de l'Aubrac là-bas
c'est Alsace Alsace Alsace
il est pas sur la recette et c'est un
produit il est sur les produits et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui fait la richesse des
fermes auberges c'est que vous mangerez
pas la même chose d'une ferme auberge à
l'autre par contre vous mangerez alors
il y a évidemment des traditionnels
vraiment on l'a dit dans le reportage
les marqueurs parce que pour les
marqueurs c'est le marqueur c'est une
traduction en français du du trailer de
vache voilà c'est vraiment c'est celui
qui trahiait les vaches rapportent le
logement qui rapporte le lait et en fait
le repas marquer c'est plus une
construction aujourd'hui autour des
produits qui sont fabriqués à la ferme
il y en a un qui est un peu standardisé
une tour en entrée c'est celle qu'on a
vu dans le reportage avec des crudités
des Roys brachelty donc ça c'est pomme
de terre
mijoté avec de avec du avec du beurre et
de l'oignon et servi avec avec du cochon
et puis ensuite du fromage évidemment et
puis en dessert du CSK donc ça c'est le
fromage frais du jour
qu'on a commode de de
une petite sauce composée
essentiellement de crème de petits lait
de sucre et de kirsch et de kirsch
toujours du kit ça c'est le repas
traditionnel finalement qu'on va trouver
dans beaucoup de femmes
le repas marque c'est le repas classique
dans les fermes auberges après toutes
les fermes auberge on développait leur
carte aujourd'hui et propose d'autres
produits de la ferme il y a des fermes
qui sont plus sur la viande voilà chez
moi j'en ai une qui fait de la salaire
donc elle va proposer sa propre viande
d'autres qui vont tourner plus autour du
fromage enfin chacune a un peu sa
spécialité
ultra locale finalement
les spécialités qui vont nous proposer
viennent toujours de la faire et ça
c'est vraiment ce qui est ce qui est
sympa enfin c'est du circuit court à
avant avant que ce soit complètement à
la mode je vous dis c'est ça fait 40 ans
au moins que le tourisme dans les Vosges
se structure autour de ces fermes
auberges alors on conjugue normalement
ferme auberge et randonnée j'ai un petit
conseil à demander à Monsieur
schenberger ce qui vaut mieux commencer
par en donner ou commencer par la ferme
auberge parce qu'après si on commence
par la fièvre
je crois que la réponse est la question
randonnée avant
posez-vous après et puis trouver un
endroit à l'ombre après
le développement les touristes et tout
qui sont venus est-ce que ça a évolué
j'allais dire de pas dans le mauvais
sens mais du côté un peu moins
authentique est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
des activités qui n'y avait pas avant
parce qu'il faut satisfaire le tourisme
aussi oui et non autour des fermes
auberge c'est resté assez traditionnel
les gens sont très respectueux il faut
le dire aussi
les Vosges c'est un match un massif donc
disais tout à l'heure qui est en Alsace
en grande partie qui est très dansé mon
peuplée depuis longtemps aménagé il y a
des sentiers de randonnée le Club
Vosgien qui est une association composée
uniquement de bénévoles fait un travail
remarquable en matière d'entretien et
d'aménagement de ses sentiers de balades
ou de randonnée
tout ça reste très respectueux les gens
qui vont en faire mauberge ils montent
avec le sac à dos il mange il repartent
en restant dans les sentiers de
randonnée ça se passe très bien ce qu'on
voit c'est plus peut-être
immédiatement accessible de nouvelles
activités arrivées sur lesquelles moi je
suis un plus critique parce que comme
quoi par exemple des locations de
trottinette pour aller électrique pour
aller pour aller en forêt là vous allez
faire du dérangement parce que ça va
amener un inflamatif de personnes dans
un endroit précis ça va déranger la
faune sauvage ça va créer des problèmes
qui derrière va se répercuter sur
l'agriculture de montagne puisque la
faune sauvage si elle est embêtée dans
son milieu naturel elle va elle va aller
plus loin donc elle va elle va être sur
les terrains des agriculteurs donc ça va
créer des dégâts pour les agriculteurs
etc etc et ça c'est des nouveaux usages
avec parfois des technologies aller
faire de la trottinette électrique
en forêt
je trouve ça un peu décalé pour se
casser la figure ça doit pas être mal
non plus je vous passe les problèmes de
casse à figure et encore une fois bon il
y a ceux qui font du VTT alors il y a
moi j'ai des VTT je dis à ceux qui
montent et il y a ceux qui descendent
quand vous faites du VTT vous êtes un
sportif que vous allez sur les sentiers
vous montez vous faites les descentes
etc c'est des gens qui sont respectueux
de l'environnement il y a aussi
une spécialité qui s'est installée les
gens ils montent en camionnette et ils
font que la descente avec des vélos de
descente ça ça dérange davantage ça crée
des risques parce que c'est pas sans
danger il faut il faut déployer
énormément de moyens de secours ensuite
voilà parfois il faut appeler un peu à
la raison aussi de nos concitoyens alors
vous disiez avec Brigitte que ça dOpel
tourisme mais en même temps il y a une
petite contradiction c'est qu'on peut
pas développer ces fermes auberge on
peut pas en construire de nouvelles donc
quel effet réel ça sur le tourisme parce
que c'est plutôt un tourisme local ou ça
attire des gens d'autres pays
internationaux il y a des Américains
dans les fermes auberge
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui attire
largement et quand on vient en Alsace je
pense qu'on ne peut pas ne pas aller
faire un tour en ferme auberge c'est
c'est une vraie spécificité par contre
il y a énormément de locaux qui vont en
fermant auberge énormément d'Alsaciens
qui te montrent le week-end ou dans la
semaine pour ceux qui ont le temps
marcher se promener faire une pause en
faire auberge soit de prendre un repas
soit l'après-midi par le beau temps se
profiter pour se poser en terrasse et
manger un dessert c'est des moments en
plein cœur de la nature très agréable
dans un milieu qui est qui est protégé
en quelque sorte donc c'est assez
exceptionnel comme comme qu'au moment
pour soi alors en Alsace il y a les
Vosges la découverte pour certains et
puis il y a aussi des vignes et des
appellations réputées dans le monde
entier le crémant tente de rivaliser
avec le champagne on en parle on met les
pieds dans le plat
et nous vous emmenons sur la route des
vins d'Alsace qui fait de cette année
c'est 70 ans l'occasion de sillonner le
vignoble l'un des plus anciens de France
l'opération Alsace rocks permet jusqu'à
fin juillet de découvrir les terroirs
les vins et le patrimoine de la région
première étape à Scherwiller avec
Stéphanie Despierres pierre Michael
Carniel et Marion Devauchelle
et Mulhouse la dégustation a lieu en
plein air au milieu des villes
Damien et Paul viticulteur font goûter
les crémants l'Alsace est l'une des
premières régions productrices de ce vin
pétillant il y a moins de mousse que
tout à l'heure par contre au niveau des
arômes il est très aromatique c'est
vraiment typique au nez de la famille
des pinots
l'Alsace attire des millions de
visiteurs chaque année les vignerons
s'appliquent à expliquer toute la
complexité de leur terroir il y a des
clés pour pour comprendre les vins
d'Alsace on a une très grande diversité
de cépages de vinification et puis
ensuite on a une gamme je pense la plus
grande de France en ayant des vins secs
des demi-secs des mois des moelleux des
liquoreux donc vous voyez que c'est des
gammes très larges une richesse de plus
en plus populaire chez les touristes aux
étrangers
j'aime beaucoup les vents alsaciens
c'est fantastique avec la gastronomie
l'histoire
et côté histoire cette touriste ne sera
pas déçu après la dégustation il est
l'heure de la balade pour la visite du
château de leur tambour s'il vous plaît
vous pouvez approcher François
appartient à l'association de protection
du château de leur tambour construit au
XIIIe siècle car en Alsace la route des
vins croise le chemin des châteaux je
trouve ici la plus forte concentration
de Château médiévaux en Europe il y en
avait 500 à l'époque il en reste à peu
près 90 visibles maintenant derrière ces
murailles de granit les randonneurs
découvrent les vestiges de la vie
médiévale à votre avis quelle était
cette pièce et à quoi pouvait servir
cette pierre avec un gros trou
non
cuisine effectivement c'est l'évier de
la cuisine
dans le dans l'ordre du château sans
vraiment se poser des questions
on a vraiment l'impression d'avoir
appris quelque chose des visites
patrimoniales des dégustations en plein
air il y en aura tous l'été pour
célébrer les 70 ans de la route des vins
d'Alsace
est-ce que vous connaissez bien la route
des vins d'Alsace je la connais bien il
se trouve qu'elle démarre dans ma
circonscription à l'anbar et Athan où on
a un des je vais me faire taper sur les
lâche jamais si 52 ou 53 grands crus
alsaciens celui du raggen et c'est là
que démarre la route des vins d'Alsace
de Thann jusqu'à Marlenheim
en vous arrêtant dans les propriétés
c'est une route du quotidien enfin moi
je viens de ce qui est mon viticole j'ai
grandi donc c'est une route que
j'emprunte tous les jours enfin pas dans
son entièreté mais il y a un bout de la
route des vins d'Alsace que j'emprunte
quasiment tous les jours donc vous avez
ces paysages magnifiques ces vignes
autour
l'inverse je vous ai ramené un vin donc
le Silvaner on a parlé avant qui vient
d'une cave coopérative je crois c'est
une des spécificités aussi de
l'agriculture en Alsace qu'elle est elle
est très largement structurée par cette
question de la coopération agricole qui
a une place importante tant dans le
vignoble que dans l'agriculture de
céréales en plaine il y a beaucoup de
place pour les coopératives c'est c'est
une des spécificités alsaciennes cette
c'est les la coopération alors les
Français connaissent le Crédit Mutuel et
son histoire alsacienne le mutualisme la
coopération ont une grande place dans le
quotidien alien puis il se trouve que le
vin que je vous ai ramené je veux en
parler parce que c'est important pour
moi c'est un Sylvaner il vient surtout
de la cave du Vieil Armand qui est le
massif Montagnier au pied duquel j'ai
grandi et puis c'est une cave qui a été
à l'époque après la guerre fondée par
quelques courageux qui ont reconstruit
qu'on reconstruit le coin qui a été qui
a été complètement détruit par la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et dans le loup
il y avait mon grand-père et c'est
quelque chose qui me tient à cœur parce
que ça raconte quelque chose de de toute
une génération qui a su se mobiliser
pour reconstruire un territoire qui
avait souffert et puis en tirer le
meilleur ce qu'il a toujours su offrir
et partager de beaux produits agricoles
et pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'important cet acte de reconstruction
et cet acte de reconstruction collective
en plus par la coopération agricole qui
permet vraiment de partager la création
de valeur d'impliquer les producteurs
dans le système économique et qui est
vraiment un beau modèle
souvent qui détiennent aussi c'est très
familial j'ai l'impression que ce soit
les fermes auberge que ce soit le vin il
y a quand même cette tradition assez
forte chez vous oui alors sur le vin
alors sur le vin il y a vraiment il y a
vraiment deux deux types d'exploitation
il y a les coopérateurs et puis il y a
les vignerons indépendants et là oui
c'est aussi des transmissions de famille
en famille les cuvées ont long des
familles mais c'est pareil c'est la
terre et la terre on la transmet et et
quand on a vocation à entretenir la
terre pour la transmettre on la respecte
et c'est moi un message que j'aime
porter en politique parce que on a
souvent un milieu agricole qui est
aujourd'hui un peu vilipendée par des
néo-ruraux par certains militants
écologistes qui viennent en expliquant
comment il faudrait bien s'occuper de la
terre non quand on est agriculteur on a
un patrimoine qu'on veut transmettre aux
générations qui suivent donc on s'occupe
bien de la terre et moi je considère
toujours de prime abord que
l'agriculture il s'occupe bien de sa
terre parce qu'il veut la transmettre
alors chaque vignoble à sa route des
vins vous connaissez celle de Bordeaux
dans la Côte du Rhône aussi autour de
Lyon le Beaujolais à des vins les vins
de Loire on leur route des vins quel est
qu'est-ce qu'il fait la spécificité de
cette route alsacienne si on la compare
aux autres déjà c'est la première c'est
à dire les autres c'est la plus vieille
route des vins en 70 ans ah c'est la
plus vieille c'est la plus ancienne elle
a inspiré les autres et puis ensuite
qu'est-ce qu'il fait sa spécificité
c'est simple c'est la plus belle mais ça
c'est très subjectif non mais parce que
j'ai l'impression que c'est toujours un
peu pareil on visite des vignobles on
déguste un peu de vin on a parfois des
châteaux c'est le cas la bordelais et là
aussi des châteaux dans votre votre
circonscription dans votre région plus
largement dans la région
l'Alsace c'est vraiment ce territoire
entre les Vosges et le Rhin
et c'est un axe de circulation majeure
en plein coeur de l'Europe c'est pas
pour rien que l'histoire de l'Alsace
elle est mouvementée sur le plan
historique et ces châteaux forts en sont
une trace pas tant d'une frontière ou de
l'existence d'une frontière passe mais
de l'existence de d'outils de
surveillance de la pleine du rein qui
était un lieu de passage et d'échange
important au cœur de l'Europe l'Europe
est une vraie réalité historique
économique sociale et de depuis
longtemps quel que soit les frontières
nationales qui ont été et l'Alsace en
est l'incarnation et il l'existence de
cette chaîne de château fort qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs et c'est assez
impressionnant des deux côtés de la rive
du Rhin tant sur les Vosges que sur le
massif de la Forêt Noire on a vraiment
deux chaînes de châteaux forts et on est
en train d'essayer de mener des
politiques pour mettre ça en évidence et
pour pas seulement parler des châteaux
forts alsaciens mais bien mettre en
évidence que c'est un réseau qui
dialogue parce qu'il permet ensemble de
surveiller la plaine du rein dans lequel
se passe
soutenu ces châteaux forts ils se
mettent énormément beaucoup d'argent
j'imagine aux communes à l'état il y en
a énormément c'est essentiellement des
ruines des c'est essentiellement des
témoins et puis il y en a quelques-uns
qui sont dans un état exceptionnel il y
en a quelques-uns le Haut-Koenigsbourg
Lebourg qui sont propriétés des grandes
collectivités et puis surtout il y a un
formidable réseau de bénévoles c'est ce
que vous avez vu dans votre reportage
qui entretient qui fait visiter qui
partage cette histoire et ça c'est la
plus grande richesse de territoire c'est
que si ce patrimoine nous est nous est
arrivé et aujourd'hui en état d'être
montré c'est parce qu'on a des bénévoles
qui s'engagent pour qui enlevé les
ronces dégager les sentiers faire un peu
de maçonnerie pour pour faire tenir tout
ça ensemble et ça c'est un engagement
qui exceptionnel j'ai une question un
peu poil à gratter on le dit la route
des vins c'est à 70 ans est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui cette expression n'est
pas un peu anachronique route associée à
20 comment associer concilier
dégustation consommation de vin et
sobriété au volant et santé est-ce que
c'est quelque chose d'abord la route des
vins c'est une route des paysages enfin
c'est quelque chose c'est quelque chose
vous traversez les vignobles alors vous
traversez les villages viticoles
et le fait de boire la question il y en
a qui déguste les puristes mais
forcément sur une route des vins on
consomme un peu de vin donc aujourd'hui
non mais c'est pas pour stigmatiser la
route des vins mais aujourd'hui quand on
entend les professionnels de santé qui
nous disent c'est zero alcool comment
concilier ces deux c'est pas d'alcool au
volant
mais mais c'est vrai
des gens qui sont pas des vrais
dégustateurs et qui peuvent être enclins
à boire un petit peu plus que d'habiter
puisqu'ils sont sur la route des vins
moi je crois que c'est la responsabilité
individuelle oui l'alcool est un produit
particulier particulièrement réglementé
c'est aussi un produit qui est
historique culturel c'est un vrai
produit culturel donc moi je vois pas de
difficulté après il y a la
responsabilité individuelle quand on
prend le volant quand on a la
responsabilité d'une famille qui est
dans le volant quand on est responsable
de son véhicule sur la route on ne
consomme pas excessivement d'alcool mais
c'est tout à fait compatible avec cette
belle route qui est une route de
paysages une route où vous allez voir
des vignobles travaillés par la main de
l'homme vous allez voir des villages
dans un état de conservation des
villages médiévaux dans un état de
conservation et de mise en valeur
exceptionnelle et vous allez en plus
découvrir des produits d'exception et de
rareté
vous ne diriez pas que c'est du
champagne quand même c'est meilleur
mais c'est le problème que nous avons
avec la création du grand test c'est que
c'est qu'on se retrouve on se retrouve
dans la même collectivité à mettre sur
le même le même niveau le champagne et
le prénom alors que alors que alors que
dans tous les concours internationaux de
20 pétillants
régulièrement des Crémants d'Alsace
arrivent devant des champagnes très
régulièrement après
pour rendre rendre à César ce qui est à
Césars
sont fabriqués grâce à la méthode
champenoise
et le plus grand vin blanc du monde
vous savez
ce que c'est
exactement
un des dix meilleurs grands crus au
monde et dans ma circonscription c'est
le Ragen de Tan c'est un vignoble dans
lequel aujourd'hui qui est sur des
terres volcaniques et dans lequel
aujourd'hui certains viticulteurs
viticulteurs vendanges en rappel
à l'automne parce que c'est très
pentueux alors on va maintenant passer
au dessert si vous le voulez bien et
c'est le péché mignon
le dessert Brigitte avec une tarte aux
myrtilles desserts traditionnel dans les
régions pouces naturellement ces petites
baies comme l'Ardèche mais aussi dans
votre région les Vosges ou cette tarte
appelée chez vous paraît-il tarte au
brunst des fameuses femmes auberges
qu'on vient de découvrir alors sans
casser l'ambiance disons tout de suite
que c'est myrtilles sont surgelés car la
saison des myrtilles cours de juillet a
début octobre mais j'imagine que vous
votre gourmandise c'est sans doute pas
rédhibitoire pour vous de manger une
tarte aux myrtilles hors saison
je vous ai je voulais vous ramener du
CSK l'épisode du siège qui a le
feuilleton ça a pas réussi à capoter
c'est un produit qui est trop fin et
trop complexe pour voyager surtout
introuvable à Paris introuvable à Paris
expliquer un petit peu ce que c'est pour
noter spectateurs on a vu les fermes
auberge dans le reportage tout à l'heure
en fait c'est le c'est le master frais
vraiment je sais être un fromage qui a
beaucoup de caractères et de goûts mais
quand il est frais c'est de la faisselle
et donc c'est un cette information frais
qu'on qu'on a saisonnes de crème de
petit lait de sucre et de kirsch et
c'est le dessert traditionnel des fermes
auberges parce que c'est vraiment le
produit du jour
on s'est rabattu sur la tarte à la
myrtille qui n'est pas moins bonne
d'ailleurs et parce que c'est l'autre
spécialité des fermes auberge c'était
une opportunité pour parler de de
l'agriculture de montagne puis ça me
rappelle toujours
l'époque où jeunes garçons ma grand-mère
nous emmenait avec mon frère pour aller
cueillir des des myrtilles à la main
pour remplir les seaux même pas au
peigne on a pas le droit normalement
on n'a pas le droit je savais pas
arriver un certain âge on avait le droit
un peu d'utiliser par Simonin et puis et
puis voilà alors certains font ça pour
aller les vendre au Thermomix
tu la dégustes la tarte à la myrtille
mais est-ce que dans les fermes auberge
ils en font tout le temps de des parce
que alors il faut le dire ça se ça se
congèle plutôt bien la myrtille ce
congèle très elle reste assez dense elle
reste un peu ferme après décongélation
là les myrtilles et goûteuses donc je
pense que les fermes auberge doivent
en fait il y a je vous dis toutes les
Fermes ouvertes sont différentes il y en
a certaines voilà qui sont peut-être
plus touristiques les autres qui ont
protège propose toute l'année parce que
c'est un produit que les gens viennent
chercher et puis il y a d'autres fermes
auberge qui font le choix de n'en
proposer que quand c'est la saison et là
vous êtes sûr de manger de la tarte la
myrtille avec des myrtilles des Vosges
dans les stations qui faisait la tarte
quand vous étiez euh
des confitures
vous allez voir Brigitte vous aurez des
belles dents bleues après ça colore les
dents bon je vais attendre un tout petit
peu
goûter là parce que on l'a déniche à
Paris dans l'une des meilleures tables
de
alors vous savez que vous dégustez on
termine toujours cette émission en
musique donc on vous en avez choisi une
on va l'écouter ensemble et puis vous
nous dites pourquoi juste après
de la ferme pas les yeux bois autour de
toi
aide-le
et de là ça pourrait t'arriver à toi
[Musique]
aide-le et de là surtout ne dis pas ça
me regarde pas
aide-le alors qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette chanson
on est à table donc j'ai pris le choix
de vous emmener un petit peu chez moi de
vous parler de moi et
ces deux choses cette chanson c'est
d'abord ceux qui la chante qui s'appelle
les tempo kids c'est un groupe de c'est
une chorale de garçon qui fait de la
variété dans laquelle j'ai été je suis
toujours et qui mène une action bien
plus que musicale qui est aussi
éducative et peut-être qu'une partie de
mon engagement vient de cette
histoire-là et c'est pour ça que j'avais
envie de partager ça avec vous à table
c'est ce qu'on fait et puis la chanson
en tant que tel c'est une chanson qui a
été écrite pour les tempo kids par
Jean-Paul carat qui est un auteur
compositeur français
qui était assez connu il a écrit la
dernière chanson qui a permis à la
France de gagner l'Eurovision en 74
ça nous est arrivé et puis c'est une
chanson qui qui a un message qui est qui
est important aussi quand on fait de la
politique c'est que on s'engage aussi
pourtant de la main on s'engage aussi
pour
ramener à la société ce qui en sont un
peu un peu éloignés et voilà c'est ces
deux ces deux choses que j'avais envie
de partager pour terminer
merci en tout cas d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en politique à table de nous
avoir fait découvrir ce beau terroir et
cette belle cuisine alsacienne merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivis on se
donne rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de politique à
table sur LCP l'espoir est une bonne qui
pleures
[Musique]
autour de toi
et de le